hello and welcome to our YouTube video
on SQL injection now you may be
wondering what is SQL injection well let
us explain SQL injection is a serious
vulnerability affecting web applications
where attackers can execute unintended
code on a server by injecting malicious
SQL commands into a database query if
successful an attacker can gain
unauthorized access to sensitive data or
even modify it so if you are a web
developer this is something you must
take seriously but don't worry in this
video we will explain how SQL injection
works why it's so dangerous and how you
can protect your application from it so
be sure to watch until the end to learn
how to safeguard your apps from this
thread before we begin if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who only sits to switch
careers with cyber security while
learning from the experts then try
giving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
activity that is in collaboration with
the modules from MIT schwarzman College
of Engineering and the course link is
mentioned in the description box that
will navigate you to the course page
where you can find a complete audio of
the program being offered and if these
are the types of videos you would like
to watch then hit the Subscribe button
like and press the Bell icon to never
miss on any update and here we go and
now we'll see the agenda for our
tutorial starting with we'll first see
what is SQL injection then we'll see how
does a SQL injection attack work then
we'll see what are types of SQL
injection tags and then we'll see the
detection and prevention of SQL
injection index then we'll see some real
life examples that happen with the SQL
injections and then we'll have an
overview of impact of SQL injection
attacks now we will start with what is
SQL injection SQL injection is a
technique used by attackers to
manipulate a web applications database
queries by injecting malicious SQL code
into input Fields attackers can execute
unauthorized commands and potentially
gain access to sensitive information
sequence injection attacks primarily
Target web applications that use SQL
databases such as MySQL Oracle or
Microsoft SQL server and now we will see
how does a SQL injection attack work so
to understand how a SQL injection attack
Works let's consider how a typical SQL
query functions queries are used to
retrieve or modify data from a database
attackers exploit vulnerable input
Fields by injecting malicious SQL code
that alters the intended behavior of the
query and attackers first study the
targeted database to understand its
structure and behavior then they craft a
SQL query that the server interprets as
a legitimate command for example or one
equal to 1 that is a queries input field
an attacker can bypass authentication
and gain access unauthorized axis and
SQL injection and tax can also be used
to delete data manipulatory codes or
retrieve information from multiple
database tables using techniques like
error-based injection Union based
attacks or inferential SQL injection now
we'll see an example to understand this
concept more so consider a website that
has search feature where users can
search for products by entering keywords
the website uses a SQL database to store
product information in a secure scenario
the website would take the user's input
sanitize it and construct a SQL query to
fetch the relevant products for example
the query might look like this that is
Select star from products where name
like and the entered keyword what they
want to search so this querying
retrieves products whose names contain
the entered keyword however if the
website is vulnerable to SQL injection
an attacker can manipulate the input to
execute medicio SQL statements let's say
the attacker wants to retrieve all
products from the database regardless of
the entire keyword in the search field
they entered or 1 equal to 1 hyphen
hyphen the input manipulates the SQL
query and this query becomes this that
is Select star from products where name
like Ampersand and then or 1 equal to 1
hyphen hyphen percent in this case the
attacker uses the single code to close
the existing string followed by or 1
equal to 1 hyphen hyphen to inject a new
condition that is always true the
semicolon is used to terminate the
previous statement and the double
hyphens are used to comment out the
remaining portion of the original query
as a result the modified query
effectively becomes that you can see on
the screen and the condition 1 equal to
1 is always true so the query retrieves
all products from the database
regardless of the keyword and this
example demonstrates how an attacker can
export a vulnerable SQL injection point
to modify the SQL queries logic and
retrieve unintended data remember this
example is simplified for educational
purposes and real world SQL injection
attacks can be more sophisticated it's
crucial to secure web applications
against SQL injection vulnerabilities to
prevent unauthorized access and data
breaches now we'll see types of SQL
injection attacks so there are different
types of SQL injection attacks that
attackers can employ let's explore a few
of them the first we will explore is
inbend SQL I I is injection here that is
in-band SQL injection so this type
includes error based and Union based
attacks where attackers use the same
channel to launch Channel attack and
collect the results and the next is
inferential SQL injection that is also
known as blind SQL injection this type
involves sending data payloads to the
database server to observe its response
without directly seeing the results it
can be either Boolean based or time
based and the next is out of band SQL
injection in cases where infant SQL
injection is not possible attackers
leverage other channels such as DNS or
HTTP request to retrieve data from the
database now we'll see detecting and
preventing SQL injection attacks so
detecting and preventing SQL injection
attacks is crucial to safeguarding web
applications here are some preventive
measures so the first measure is train
employees own preventive methods that is
educate your ID teams including
developers and system administrators on
SQL injection attack vectors and
prevention techniques next we could do
is Implement input validation and
parameterized queries validate and
filter user input using an allow list
approach and use parameterized queries
or prepaid statements to separate SQL
code from user input that will not allow
any malicious hacker to enter any SQL
code into the input method and the next
is regular security scans perform
regular security scans to identify and
address potential vulnerabilities in web
applications and the next is keep
software up to date that is ensure that
all software including databases and
programming languages are regularly
updated to include the latest security
patches and protections against SQL
injection and now we'll see some real
life examples of SQL injection attacks
so let's take a look at some real life
examples the first is Tesla
vulnerability in 2014 security
researchers discovered a SQL injection
vulnerability on Tesla's website which
allowed attackers to gain administrative
privileges and access user data this was
one of the SQL injection attacks and the
next was fortnite vulnerability in 2019
a SQL injection vulnerability was found
in fortnite that could have enabled
attackers to access user accounts the
vulnerability was promptly patched and
the nexo's Cisco vulnerability in in
2018 a SQL injection vulnerability in
Cisco Prime license manager granted
attackers shell access to computers with
the install license management system
Cisco addressed the issue promptly and
last not the least we'll see the impact
of SQL injection attacks so the impact
of SQL injection attacks can be
devastating for businesses the first
could be the unauthorized access to
sensitive information and resources and
the next is potential data breaches and
exposure to confidential data and the
next is data manipulation or deletion
and the next is Network infiltration and
system compromise and the next is blows
of customer trust and decreased revenue
and the last is reputational damage and
long-term consequences for the business
and that wraps up our discussion on SQL
injection it's crucial for businesses
and developers to be aware of this
vulnerability and take necessary
precautions to prevent attacks stay
vigilant keep your software up to date
it and educate yourself and your team on
best practices for web application
security and with that we have reached
the end of this tutorial let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years
old and last year I obscure was simply
learns post-graduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
IIT sector in various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course course I must
say was packed with practical examples
it was led by highly skilled certified
instructors with many companies before
the security analysts and the architect
on a contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant
happened on the first if you have any
questions please feel free to comment
and will have it answered for you as
soon as possible until next time thank
you for watching stay safe keep learning
and get ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign